[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام لماذا يتهافت
العرب على التطبيع مع اسرائيل كما لو انه
سيكون العلاج الشافي لكل مشاكلهم
وازماتهم وكوارثهم السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والمعيشيه
ماذا استفاد المطبعون السابقون واللاحقون
لماذا لا ينظر النظام السوداني حوله مثلا
قبل ان يسقط في الحضن الاسرائيلي الا
تقفوا بعض الدول العربيه المطبعه مع تل
ابيب منذ عقود الا تقف اليوم على كف عفريت
اقتصاديا ومعيشيا هل تريد اسرائيل التطبيع
مع العرب ام التركيعه حسره الم يحدث كل
هذا الخراب والدمار في المنطقه اصلا كي
تنام اسرائيل قريره العين فلماذا تقدمون
لها مزيدا من الهدايا والعطايا المجانيه
لكن في المقابل ماذا استفادى بتوع
المقاوله المتحالفون مع ايران من
مسرحياتهم المقاومجيه ضد اسرائيل الا تعيش
كل الدول التي تعادي تل ابيب تحت تحت الم
يلعب البعبع الايراني ايضا دورا رئيسيا في
دفع العربي الى الحضن الاسرائيلي ثم لماذا
يعارض بعض الفلسطينيين تطبيع العرب مع
اسرائيل وهم ينامون اصلا في الحضن
الاسرائيلي او الايراني الا يبقى التقارب
العربي مع اسرائيل على علاته افضل الف مره
من التحالف مع نظام الملالي اسئله اطرحها
هنا في الاستوديو على الكاتب والناشط
الدكتور ابراهيم حمامي وعبر الاقمار
الصناعيه من فيينا على الكاتب والنشر ثائر
الناشف
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس دكتور
ابراهيم لو بدات معك كيف تفسر هذه الهجمه
يعني غير المسبوقه اذا صح التعبير من قبل
العرب على التطبيع مع اسرائيل اصبحت
زرافات زرافات البعض يقول فالماضي كانت من
تحت لتحت الان صارت من تحت لا تخت كيف ترد
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك دكتور
فيصل المشاهدين الكرام
وتحيه لكل اهلنا وشعبنا في كل مكان في هذا
الوطن الكبير وجميل من جديد
اولا اسمح لي ان اشعر بالاسف والاسى اننا
نتحدث اليوم بدلا نتحدث عن التحرير ومعركه
التحرير وتحرير فلسطين نتحدث عن التطبيع
واين وصل وهذه الرده الغريبه التي نعيشها
اليوم ثانيا اسمح لي ان اتبرا وان اقول
اني لا احترم ولا اتشرف ابدا بمشاركه ايا
من دعاه التطبيع ومروجين سوره الاحتلال
وتجميل صورته من الصحن العرب هكذا اسمهم
ولا اسم اخر لهم سنشركم ولكن للضروره
احكام ثالثا كل هؤلاء وكل محاولات لهذا
التطبيق لا زالت فاشله في ان تصل الى
الجمه العربي والشعب العربي في هذا
التطبيق لا يوجد تطبيع شيء وتطبيع سيء
واضحين كل التطبيق كل اشكاله وانواعه هم
مصادره من اي طرف كان هو مرفوض ما يجري
اليوم في المنطقه دكتور فيصل تجاوز
التطبيع اما اصبح هناك استسلام كامل
وهيمنه اسرائيليه كامله او اصبحت شراكه مع
المحتال ضد كل ما هو حلم عربي او تمنيات
وتطلعات الشعوب العربيه منذ ما بدات مع
مرحله التطبيع والاختراق الاستراتيجي في
مصر في عام 77 في زياره القدس التي قام
بها السادات وهناك محاوله لفرض التطبيع
الشعبي التطبيع الرسمي موجود كما ذكرت في
مقدمتك من تحت الطاوله من فوق طاوله لكن
موجود لكن لما اصبح غنيا في 77 ثم
اتفاقيات 79 حاولوا فرض التطبيع على الشبه
مصر على سبيل المثال معرض الكتاب محاوله
الزيارات فرضه في الفن الى اخره رفض الشعب
المصري بالكامل ولم يستطع القيام بذلك لكن
ما يحدث اليوم هو محاوله لكي الوعي العربي
وفرض التطبيع الشعبي بالقوه وعنوه وسنتحدث
عن هذه الاشكاليات لكنه بقي تطبيقا رسميا
دكتور فيصل وفشل شعبيا والدليل الاكبر وما
حدث في كاس العالم الاخير في المونديال
الاخير
بتحيه لاصحاب وشباب وابداعات حلم فلسطيني
الذين قاموا بعمل جبار اضطر الاعلام
العبري يعترف به عن فشل التطبيع شعبيا
اقتباسات سريعه جدا في 27 نوفمبر 2022 من
شهرين قالوا بعد مرور 26 سنه اقتباس حرفي
وبرغم اتفاقيات ابراهام التي اطلق اطلقت
صفيره قطار التطبيع بين الدوله العبريه
واربع الدول العربيه كذا وكذا وكذا وجد
صحفيين انفسهم وهم يلقنون الدرس نفسه في
المونديال معاريف في 10 ديسمبر 2022 واحد
اسمه شحار
طلع بعنوان اسمه هزمت اسرائيل يتحدث عن
فشل التطبيع الشعبي بان الشعب العربي يرفض
الاسرائيليين بالصوت والصوره ثم 16 ديسمبر
2022 تتحدث عن الانتصار الكبير في
المونديال هو التضامن العربي مع فلسطين
والعالم الفلسطيني وانا كانت دوله لا
تردين في المونديال لندخل في هذا التفاصيل
اذن الاعلام العبري يتحدث بشكل مباشر
وواضح ان التطبيع الشعبي فاشل تماما وهذا
محاوله فرضه اليوم بمعنى انه قبل عقود
فشلوا في مصر واليوم يفشلون في ف الشعبي
لكن في ذات الوقت تنطلق ابواق رخيصه
وادوات رخيصه في محاوله تجميل صوره
الاحتلال ومحاوله فرض هذا التطبيع وشيطنه
كل ما له علاقه بالقضيه الفلسطينيه وقضايا
الشعوب العربيه هذه الادوات تعمل بطريقه
الهاتف المسبق الدفع زي ما بقولنا في
العراق ايش قد تحط بيه ايش قد يتكلم تعطيه
بشتغل لكن ليس بالضروره انا بقول ليس ان
تكون عميلا تخدم العدو يكفي ان تكون غبيا
وللاسف هذه الادوات معظمها يتحدث اما عن
قصد واما عن غباء خلاصه القول التطبيع ما
زال رسميا فاشلا مرفوض شعبيا لا فائده منه
على الاطلاق للدول المطبعه والتي تريد
له سقطوا وانتهوا وليس بالضروره ان يكونوا
كما قلت عملاء ولكنهم اغبياء في ابسط جميل
جدا ثائر الناشف كيف ترد على هذه المقدمه
يعني تطبيع غير تطبيع كله فشل وكل من
يحاول ان يدخل هذه اللعبه سيفشل كيف ترد
هذا ليس دقيقا دكتور فيصل لكن بالبدايه
اعزي اهالينا السوريين بسبب هذا الزلزال
المدمر الذي اصابهم في تركيا وحلب وتوقيع
وقوفا عند سؤال حضرتك ومقدمه ضيفك دكتور
فيصل الجميع يحاول ان يرش السكر على الموت
كما يقال بانه يتعلق بموضوع التطبيع اليوم
لم يعد هناك شيئا يعيب العرب جميعا في ان
يطبعوا علاقاتهم او يوقعوا علاقات او
اتفاقيات سلام مع اسرائيل لان الواقع
العملي والتجريبي اليوم اثبت بكل صوره
دقيقه وحيه ان الواقع اليوم يشيء ان
اسرائيل ليست دوله سائله او انها الى
السقوط الدول العربيه اليوم تعاني من
ازمات اقتصاديه بسبب تدخل ايران وبسبب
احتلالها لاربع دول عربيه الدول التي طبعت
علاقاتها اليوم مع اسرائيل تعيش بافضل
احوالها مقارنه بالدول التي لم تطبق مع
ايران والتي استخدمت خطاب العداء وخطاب
التحريض نتج عنه ان الشعوب العربيه حتى
اليوم ما تزال تغرق في نظريات المؤامره في
حين ان الدموع الدول العربيه التي وقعت
اتفاقيات سلام مع اسرائيل استطاعت ان تحقق
نوعا من التنميه الاقتصاديه ان تحقق نوعا
من الاستقرار السياسي والامني وهذا مثال
واضح وحي على ما يحدث اليوم في بلدان
الخليج العربي وكذلك الامر في بلدان
المغرب وكذلك شمال افريقيا واليوم السودان
يتجه نحو التوقيع اتفاقيه سلام لكن للاسف
الصوره مغلوطه اليوم حول التطبيع تتم
دائما شيطنه هذه الكلمه لكي يبدو التطبيع
وكانه ردسون من عمل الشيطان فاجتنبوه لكن
الواقع والحقيقه ان مصر اليوم ومنذ بعد
اتفاقيه كام ديفيد وحتى الان استفادت
كثيرا من هذه الاتفاقيه حققت بعض التنميه
الاقتصاديه وكذلك ايضا
العالم على مصر استثمارات اجنبيه جاءت الى
مصر كذلك ايضا منشات سياحيه كبيره وهائله
عماله مصريه بالالاف توجد في اسرائيل
وكذلك ايضا مصانع امريكيه افتتحت في مصر
مليارات قدمت لمصر كمعون من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بموجب ترتيبات اتفاقيه
كام ديفيد هذا ما يخص مصر وحدها ايضا
الاردن نفس الامر استفاد كثيرا ربما بلدان
الخليج العربي ليست بحاجه الى دعم من
امريكا او دعم حتى من اسرائيل على المستوى
المادي فلديها ما يكفيها من ثروات
وامكانيات ولكن اتحدث عن دول مثل مصر
والاردن والمغرب لديها ازمات اقتصاديه
اسرائيل ليست مسؤوله عن هذه الالزامات
ولكن الدول هي التي والشعوب هي المسؤوله
عن ازماتها لكن اسرائيل حقيقه حتى الان
تجاه مصر وتجاه الاردن وفاه بجميع
التزاماتها فيما يتعلق باتفاقيات الغاز
وكذلك ايضا باتفاقيات الامنيه يعني الجيش
المصري لم يكن يس بالوصول الى مناطق معينه
في سيناء جرى قبل ثلاثه اعوام السماح
للجيش المصري بالوصول الى مناطق كانت حتى
محظوره عليه في اتفاقيه كانت ديفيد وخاصه
بعد ان شاعت الفوضى في مناطق واسعه في
سيناء نتيجه اضطرابات الحاله الامنيه نفس
الامر تكرر كذلك في بلدان اخرى كالمغرب
وغيرها بالنسبه لما يتعلق بموضوع مونديال
قطر نعم هناك ربما بعض الصحفيين
الاسرائيليين الذين تعرضوا لمواقف يعني
سلبيه من بعض المشجعين ولكن هذا لا يعكس
الصوره الحيه هناك صحفيون اسرائيليون
وصلوا الى المونديال وغطوا بكل اريحيه
ونقلوا انطباعات ايجابيه عن دوله قطر
والشعب القطري ومنهم صحفي التقيت به رعي
قيس والتقى بطل راليات قطر حمد السويدي
وقدم له هديه المونديال وكانت هناك
انطباعات ايجابيه وهذا ما يعزز الصوره
الايجابيه للعرب لان اسرائيل تملك مثل هذا
الاتصال الكبير مع بلدان الغرض فالاعلام
الاسرائيلي هو الوجه الاخر للاعلام الغربي
حقيقه فعندما يتم خطاب الكراهيه والعداء
لاسرائيل ينتقل هذا الخطاب مباشره الى
الغرب والسيد ابراهيم حمامي يعيش فيه
بريطانيا ويعلم جيدا ما هو تاثير الاعلام
الاسرائيلي على الاعلام البريطاني وغيرها
وسائل الاعلام الاجنبيه فلذلك كله الصوره
اليوم للعرب يجب ان تكون صوره ايجابيه
جميل جدا كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
في الموضوع مباشره اول شيء هو يقول ان
شيطن التطبيع وكان نعم التطبيع الشيطان
طيب
يقول انا مونديال قطر اعطى مواقف سلبيه مع
الاعلام المصريه بل هي مواقف قمه في
الايجابيه من الجمهور العربي والاجنبي
ايضا وليس العربي فقط في مقاطعه لكن
لنتذكر بدايه فوائد التطبيل العرب هو ذكر
مصر تحديدا لنذكر ان هدف الاحتلال الازلي
هو السيطره والهيمنه على العرب يقول في
عام 2009 وهو استاذ علاقات لذلك الوقت
وانقل حرفيا ما كتبه في صحيح الجاردن في
سبعه يناير 2009 باختصار ان الهدف ليس هدف
ليس التعايش السلمي وانما السيطره
العسكريه
نتنياهو في 28/12 الماضي قبل يوم الاعلان
الحكومته يعني نشر على التويتر وقال للشعب
اليهودي حصري في جميع مناطق اسرائيل وضمه
من ضمن المناطق يهودا والسامر الضفه
الغربيه هم لا يريدون لا سلام ولا تطبيع
ولا يريدون هيمنه لكن حتى ندخل في موضوع
وليس هذا من باب نقد من طبعه هم احرار
يعني احنا نتحدث انه التطبيق مرفوض جمله
تفصيله ولكن خلينا ننسى المبادئ والعقيده
وكل شيء ونحط بشكل ميكافيلي كامل تحدث عن
مصر من حتى اليوم مصر في عام 77 كانت
بالمعايير الاقتصاديه ومعايير الفقر
ومعايير المرض ومعايير الجهل زيها زي
تركيا زيها زي ماليزيا اين تركيا اليوم
اين ماليزيا اليوم واين مصر اليوم التي
قالت ان التطبيع او اتفاقيه السلام على
ستنهي حاله العداء ونستطيع ان ندخل في
الانفتاح الاقتصاد هكذا اسمه سياسه
الانفتاح السادات اين المصري اليوم يتحدث
عن مليارات مصر اليوم على شفا اعلان
الافلاس على شفا الانهيار التام بعد
اتفاقيات التطبيع والسلام التي يتحدث عنها
سيناء التي يتحدث عنها ويقول ان دخل الجيش
المصري دخلها باتفاقيه مع اسرائيل لمده
محدده فقط لملاحقه ناس كانوا بيطاردوهم
بمساعده الجيش الاسرائيلي وعدد الدبابات
والرشاشات والافراد كله محدوده بالرقم
وبالتالي لا سياده مصر على سيناء وهذا ليس
يعني سر معروف باتفاقيات موجوده ايضا
دخلنا في بعض الدول الاخرى على سبيل
المثال السودان هو نفسه خرج قبل ثلاث
اعوام صحيح ساطع من الحزب الناصري وكان
يتحدث انه حتجيب وتعمل برهان لما التقى
بين نتنياهو اليوم التقى برهان بالكوهين
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي من جديد ثلاث
سنوات شو صار مع السودان لو رفعت من
الارهاب ولا تحسن اقتصاب والجنيه السوداني
في الارض في الحضيض واقتصاد السودان حتفلس
زيها زي غيرها هم صدق كتبت دكتور كما قال
ست الدول العربيه على وشك الافلاس من
ضمنهم السودان من ضمنهم مصر ماذا يتحدث
عنه في التنميه شمال افريقيا لا يوجد هذا
الكلام اذا دخلنا على دول اخرى المغرب
طبعوا حسب مذكرات الاخيره وزير الخارجيه
امريكا بسبب الامريكي بسبب يريد اعتراف
الولايات المتحده بالمغربيه الصحراء وهذا
حق مشروع اولوي لهم لكن ما الذي حدث الذي
حدث ان نتنياهو خرج في ديسمبر 2020 بعد
عمليه تطبيع مع المغرب بخريطه وراه ما فيش
فيها المغرب اشتزت الصحراء من المغرب ثم
خرج مبين شباته يهودي مغربي الاصل كان في
وفد الذي ذهب المغرب بتوقي ويقول ان حتى
هذه اللحظه 2020 حتى هذه اللحظه اسرائيل
لم تعترف بعد مغربيه الصحراء هذا هو
الاحتلال يطعن في الظهر يعمل اتفاقيه في
الظهر اما الدول الاخرى ما عندهاش مشاكل
تنمويه والاخره زي الامارات الامارات ما
عندهاش مشاكل تنمويه وربنا فاتح اليوم فش
مشكله دخلت في اتفاقيات شراكه مع اسرائيل
بالعشرات يقول
وزير شؤونه مستوطنات ساحه في 25 اغسطس
تقول انه هناك اتفاقيه انه فقط طلع نتيجه
وكذب الامر وقال انه خبر مكذوب بعد شهرين
وافق كيف وافقوا ان تباع اسلحه الامارات
استراتيجيه لم تشمل
35 ولكن بشرط التفوق الاسرائيلي العسكري
الكامل في المنطقه وبالتالي حتى الذين
دخلوا في هذه الاتفاق التطبيع اسرائيل
تسعى الى الهيمنه المطلقه والسيطره على
هذه المطلقه بالمطلق وعدم السماح للعرب
اما ان يتحرروا ديمقراطيا ويتحرر الشعوب
وتحقق اهدافها او ان تتفوق لا علميا ولا
اقتصاديا ولا تنمويا والى اخره الذي دخل
في التطبيع لم يجنو شيء اخر مثال حاعطيك
اياه المعرض السوري اللي هو 4 ذهب الى
اسرائيل
قدمان وعبد الجليل السعيد وكمان هو ذهب
الى اسرائيل لدعمهم ضد نظام بشار الاسد ما
الذي شنوه من هذا الالتماء اسرائيل
انا لم اذهب انا لم اذهب الى اسرائيل ولم
ازور اسرائيل مطلقا ولن ازورها بالمناسبه
الدول العربيه جميعا
هدوا اسرائيل بالمناسبه
مشاعر الشعب الفلسطيني
هناك انا
رجل نظريات المؤامره الاسرائيلي
يعني بالنسبه لموضوع التطبيع لا اريد ان
اذهب الى بعيدا يا دكتور فيصل سابقى في
صلب القضيه
المعني الاول في موضوع التطبيع اليوم
هو الشعب الفلسطيني والقضيه الفلسطينيه
الفلسطينيه اليوم اين هم هم من طبعوا
العلاقات الشعبيه والاجتماعيه والسياسه
والاقتصاديه مع اسرائيل يتعاملون مباشره
مع الغاز والكهرباء والاتصالات
الاسرائيليه والشيكل الاسرائيلي في قطاع
غزه يعني قطاع غزه الذي لديه وضع خاص
واستثنائي فيما يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
يتعامل مباشره مع اسرائيل بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين في منطقه السلطه في الضفه
الغربيه ايضا والشرقيه لديهم تعامل مع
اسرائيل على مستوى السلطه وعلى مستوى
الاحزاب وعلى مستوى الحكومه الفلسطينيه
كذلك الامر بالنسبه لعرب الداخل ماذا
احدثك عن عرب الداخل يا دكتور فيصل يحملون
الباسبورات الاسرائيليه يتعاملون مع
الاسرائيليين كانهم يعني شعب واحد انا
التقيت فلسطينيين في اوروبا هم كانوا في
مجموعه سياحيه واحده مع اسرائيليين
مواطنات فلسطينيات محجبات يعني مسلمات
التقيت بهم في احدى سياحيه في النمسا
وسالتهم انتم فلسطينيون هل لديكم مشكله او
اعداء مع اسرائيل قالت لي انظر من يقودنا
في الوفد مواطن اسرائيلي هو من يقود الوفد
ذهبت الى هذا الاسرائيلي وتحدثت اليه قلت
له الصوره النبطيه في الاعلام العربي انكم
انتم تقتلون الشعب الفلسطيني فهل هذا صحيح
اجبني قال لي انظر بعينك الفلسطينيون معنا
يحملون الجوازات يتمتعون بنفس الحقوق التي
نتمتع بها يذهبون بجواز سفر يسمح لهم
بدخول كل دول العالم بدون فيزا وبدون
استثناء
الفلسطينيون اليوم يعيشون في وضع اقتصادي
افضل بكثير من البلدان التي ترفع شعارات
المقاومه والمماطعه والصمود والتصدي
المواطن الفلسطيني اليوم دخله هو بالحد
الادنى افضل من دخل اي مواطن عربي يعيش
فيه خارج منطقه الخليج العربي اعني حتى لا
اكون مبالغا واقول ان دخل المواطن
الفلسطيني افضل من دخل المواطن الامارات
او القطري لكن بكل تاكيد هو افضل من دخل
الم الجزائري الذي يتشدق اليوم بشعارات
حكومته وبشعارات الصمود والتصدي التي عفا
عليها الزمن المواطن الفلسطيني اليوم سواء
في غزه او في داخل الخط الاخضر في مدن
الناصره او مدن حيفا يتمتع بدخل لا يقل عن
دخل اي مواطن اوروبي يعيش في دول اوروبا
الغربيه وليس في دول اوروبا الشرقيه ماذا
يريد الانسان العربي اكثر من ذلك يا دكتور
فيصل يريد ان يعيش بحياه امنه حره كريمه
وايضا يمارس حقه اليوم الكتله العربيه في
اسرائيل انظر الى منصور عباس ماذا فعله
اصبح صانع الملوك في اسرائيل يا دكتور
فيصل اصبحت الاحزاب الاسرائيليه تتشدق به
وهو اسلامي بالمناسبه يعني هو من خط
اسلامي ربما من نفس خط الدكتور ابراهيم
حمامي ايضا ماذا عن النواب العرب في
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي صالوا وجالوا وذهبوا
الى بلدان عربيه وبعضهم اتخذ مواقف حتى ضد
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يعني يفترض انني كعضو
في برلمان ان اكون متوافقا مع سياسات
الدوله اعيش بها لكن مع ذلك علوا الصوت
رفعوا الصوت عاليا ووقفوا في وجه نواب
اسرائيليين من احزاب يمينيه واحزاب متشدده
وعبروا عن غضبهم وعبروا عن استنكارهم
للسياسات الاسرائيليه ضمن اطار
الديمقراطيه وضمن اطار الحقوق التي يتمتع
بها انسان انا لا اريد ان اقول ان اسرائيل
جنه وان اسرائيل هي بيت الله على الارض هي
دوله طبيعيه مثلها مثل اي دوله في اوروبا
او في المشرق العربي كل ما هنالك انه لا
يوجد فساد عندهم لا يوجد عندهم نهب لا
يوجد عندهم استلاب لحقوق الاخرين يعيشون
ضمن مساحه واحده نعم هناك ربما تمييز ربما
هناك عنصريه وهذا يوجد في كل دول العالم
دكتور فيصل في امريكا حتى اليوم يوجد
تمييز عنصري بين البيض والسود في بلدان
العربيه يوجد تمييز بين قبيله واخرى يا
دكتور فيصل يعني اذا كان هناك تمييز في
اسرائيل ضد احد ما او من جهه الى اخرى
فهذا الامر يحدث في كل المجتمعات هذا من
احدى الامراض الاجتماعيه التي يعاني منها
الانسان سواء في نطاق الدوله او في نطاق
المجتمع يعني انا اريد ان اقول ان
الفلسطينيين اليوم هم المعنيين بموضوع
المساله وما يتعلق بالعلاقه مع اسرائيل
مطبعون مع اسرائيل بشكل ايجابي وانا لا
الومهم على ذلك على العكس تماما انا هذا
الامر يفرحني اني اجد الفلسطينيين بوضع
افضل مما هم عليه لان الفلسطينيين حقيقه
عانوا وهذا لا نحن ونحن لا ننكره ونحن لا
نعيب عليهم على العكس مطلقا عندما الشعب
الفلسطيني يجد حياه امنه وحره ومستقره
فهذا امر ايجابي نعم الفلسطينيون قاوموا
اسرائيل بالسلاح وكانت هناك رده فعل قويه
وحققت هذه يعني الحركه الفلسطينيه
المقاومه حققت مكاسب لاكوب ولكن النضال
السلمي بدا فعلا منذ 20 عاما وهذا هو
الطريق الصحيح للشعب الفلسطيني الذي بداه
طريق المفاوضات السياسيه طريقه تطبيع طريق
انك تستطيع ان تجابه اسرائيل بالكلمه اكثر
ما تجبها بالسلاح لانك ايضا تعلم جيدا ان
اسرائيل تتضامن معها كثير من دول العالم
لها علاقات قويه مع الغرب وبالتالي اليوم
عندما انت تريد ان تواجه اسرائيل عسكريه
فانت لا تتكافئ معها في ميزان القوه وبنفس
الوقت العالم كله سوف يستنكر رده العسكريه
وصلت الفكره وبالتالي ستخسر اكثر مما
ستكسب لكنك جميل جدا كيف ترد
لانك ماشي على الكتالوج ابدا يعني ترويج
التطبيع تجميل احتلال لابد ان يقرن
بتشيطنه تشويه شعب الفلسطيني وبالتالي
القول الفلسطيني عايشين ومبسوطين وعايشين
تحت الاحتلال فش احلى من هيك وبياخذوا
فلوس وبياكل وبيشربوا بينام وبيتكاثر زي
زباقيه الانعام وهل تستطيع ان تشكك في هذا
الكلام
بس بدي اسالك بس نحن عندنا بس بس هذه
مطروحه الان بالله
بيخجلوا منه انت هون 25 يناير 2011 في هذا
الاستوديو طلب واحد ناطق رسمي
منه لكن السؤال الحقيقي هل برايك الشعب
الفلسطيني مطبع الجواب ياتي من اول السنه
لحد اليوم كل ساعتين في جريح كل عشرين
ساعه في شهيد هذا في الضفه الغربيه الجواب
ياتي من غزه التي تقارن الاحتلال ليله
نهار وتجهز لمعركه التحرير ان شاء الله
الجواب الحقيقي في اسقاط كل الاتفاقيات
والمعاهدات والصفقات التي حاولت اسقاط
الحق الفلسطيني الجواب ياتي انك تجد
فلسطيني واحد محترم او غير محترم يقبل
التطبيع بهذا الشكل بهذا الشكل الفج بينما
تجد العشرات من من
المطبين العرب بين قوسين ينهقون ليله نهار
يعني سؤال يطرح الان بس خليني اسالك طيب
يعني هل يحق للفلسطيني الذي ينام ليل نهار
في الحضن الاسرائيلي ياكل من اسرائيل
وياخذ راتبه من اسرائيل ويعمل كل شيء
وعندما تتبع اي بلد عربي او اي بلد عربي
مع اسرائيل تثور ثائرته وقال لا يريد
التطبيع ما انت نايم بحضنه طيب عم تحكي
على موضوع اخر حكينا فيه هذا تمام
الكساجين في السجن السجان بيعطيك اكلك
وشربك وانت تطلع وانت تروح تجي انت احتلال
بتامل احتلال غصب عنك فش عندك خط اخر
الامور الحياتيه المعيشيه اليوميه انت
مجبر معها لكن هل الفلسطيني وقع على
التناسب
لما تكون في السجن لما بتختار من سجان اما
لنفترض جدلا الفلسطيني طبع وتخلى وتنازل
وعمل كل شيء
ماشي هل الاقصى كمسلمين لو اجا حاكم في
المستقبل بعد عشرين سنه بعد خمسين سنه بعد
سنه وسلم مكه والمدينه لطاف اخر لايران
اللي بتحبوها كتير هل نقول ما دخل هذه مكه
والمدينه خاصه باهل الحجاز والنجم
السعوديين هذه عقيده هذه قضيه كل انسان
عربي مسلم شريف حر في هذا العالم
اصلا وهو ليس اطلاقا انه
تركنا القضيه كلياتها الى اخره طيب ليش
لحد اليوم تسعى الى الحصول على الشرعيه
الفلسطيني خلاص ترك كل شيء وخلصت القضيه
لماذا الذين يطبعون حتى هذه اللحظه
يتعذرون بفلسطين ونحن والله بدنا نساعد
فلسطين بالتطبيق تبعنا لانه القضيه لم
تنتهي والفصيل لم يتناسب اما موضوع العيش
شغله واحده الموضوع اعضاء الكنيست ومنصور
عباس كلام يعني ماسق ما بنردش عليه لكن
لنذهب الى تقارير منظمه دوليه وفي مرات
تتحدث عن نظام فصل عنصري كامل لا نتحدث عن
عنصريه هنا هناك قبيله وغيرها زي ما حكا
نظام فصل عنصري كامل الذي حدث في سيف
القدس عندما صار اهنا في 48 كان واضحا ما
الذي يعنيه ان الفلسطيني يرفض هذا
الاحتلال بعد كل محاولات التسجيل من عام
48 حتى اليوم هذا الكلام الفلسطيني لم
يطبع القياده الفلسطينيه
قياده عربيه تمثل الشعب والمحك الحقيقي
والرئيسه يا سيد تمتدع شيء هل تقبل ان
يكون هناك استفتاء عربي بكل الشعوب
العربيه على التطبيع يرفضون ذلك جمله
وتفصيله بس يا دكتور هناك من يقول ان معظم
الدول العربيه الفاشله الان شعوبها بس
دقيقه شعوب الدول العربيه اقول لك الان
يعني هل لو ذهبت مثلا الى الشعب العراقي
سيرفض التطبيع او السوري او اللبناني او
الليبي يا رجل الان اصبح المنطقه اصبحت
مستباحه والكل يريد ان يتخلص من هذه من
هذه الطعم الحاكمه هل تعتقد ان هناك مشكله
خطا كبير هذه الطقم هي جزء من هذه
المنظومه الاحتلال هل مثلا النظام في
سوريا غير مدعوم من الاحتلال هل كان ليبقى
12 سنه من الثوره السوريه لولا دعم
الاحتلال له ونتذكر ونتذكر رامي مخلوف
طبعا طيب ثائر الناشف يعني انت تقدم عمليه
التطبيع مع اسرائيل على ضوء ما يحدث الان
انت كما كما قلت يعني لاءات الخرطوم
الثلاث لا تفاوض لصلح لا اعتراف يعني كان
البعض ساخرا يقول ان العرب في ذلك الوقت
كانوا صادقين فعلا لا يريدون ان يعترفوا
باسرائيل ولا يريدون ان يتصالحوا مع
اسرائيل ولا يريدون اي شيء لانهم في واقع
الامر كانوا يستعدون جميعا
للانطباء للانبطاح دفعه واحده كما كما
يحصل الان السؤال الذي يطرح الان يطرح
الان هل تستطيع ان تذكر يا ثائر الناشف ان
كل ما حصل في المنطقه من خراب وتدمير
وتهجير واعاده
البلدان المجاوره خمسين عاما الى الوراء
هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان كل ذلك حصل من اجل
عيون اسرائيل الذي التي تريد من العرب ان
يطبعوا معها
كي تنام اسرائيل قريره العين كل ما يحدث
الان واخر لبنان وتدمير مرفا لبنان وفرض
وفرض الاستسلام على لبنان بالمناسبه البعض
يقول ان لبنان طبع مع اسرائيل لم يحصل على
شرف التطبيع غصب عنه رسم الحدود واعطت
للترباعه لاسرائيل كيف تريد ان تطبع مع
كيان لا يستطيع ان يعيش الا اذا دمر كل
المنطقه من حوله كل المنطقه دمرت من اجل
اسرائيل كيف ترد هذا الكلام الشارع العربي
كله يقوله
تمام دكتور يعني اليوم اولا التطبيع عندما
يتم بين اسرائيل واي دوله عربيه انت تلاحظ
ان التطبيع اسرائيل اصلا لا تطبع مع دول
ضعيفه دول منهوكه السياده التطبيع دائما
يكون بين طرفين متساويين في القوه اليوم
مصر طبعت بعد حرب اكتوبر الاردن نفس الامر
كان هناك نزاع اردني اسرائيلي كذلك الامر
ربما في السودان ايضا دخل في مرحله صراع
مع اسرائيل اليوم اذا كانت هناك دوله
عربيه تريد ان تطبع مع اسرائيل واسرائيل
قبلت بالتطبيع فهذا امر ايجابي لان ذلك
يعود بالنفع على هذه الدوله وليس يعود
بالنفع على اسرائيل قدر ما يعود بالنفع
على تلك الدوله العربيه
انت تقول اسرائيل لا تطبع مع دول ضعيفه يا
سيدي البعض يقول ان التطبيع الحاصل الان
بين بعض العرب واسرائيل هو كالتطبيع بين
الذئب والحمل ليس هناك معك حق التطبيع يجب
ان يكون بين اطراف متعادله بالقوه تستفيد
من التطبيع لكن اسرائيل هنا لا تريد
التطبيع اسرائيل تريد التركيع تريد
التركيع يعني كل الذين يتهافتون على
اسرائيل الان خوفا يعني النظام السوداني
بالله النظام السوداني النظام السوداني
يرى في اسرائيل يعني نوع من الحمايه كله
يتهافت على اسرائيل انا بدي اسالك انت
ذكرت بعض الدول وزير المياه والري الاردني
الاسبق منذر الحدادين قبل فتره قبل فتره
الذي طبعت بلاده علاقتها مع ت كان صريحا
جدا عندما ساله المذيع عن رايه في سرقه
اسرائيل للمياه الاردنيه فاجابه حدادين
اسرائيل لا تسرق المياه الاردنيه مطلقا
ولا تحتاج اصلا لللجوء الى اساليب السرقه
اسرائيل تغتصب كل ما تريد جهارا نهارا
امام اعيننا ولا نستطيع حتى ان نشتكي او
نتدمر فما بالك ان نمانع او نرفع صوتنا
هذا هو الكلام هذا الكلام ينسحب على كل
العرب دون استثناء لبنان لبنان الان عندما
وقع ترسيم الحدود لم يوقع تطبيع وقع شو
اسمه بيروت وين راح مين ضرب مرفا بيروت
ومين عمل مرفا بيروت لا تحاولي تجمل القصه
الكل المنطقه الان تذبح وتداس من اجل
اسرائيل
تفضل
دكتور يعني انا لم ارى ان اسرائيل هي من
يعني من دمر ميناء بيروت الامر واضح حزب
الله هو المسؤول وايران يعني ايران اليوم
تفتح الحروب وازمات وفتن طائفيه في
المنطقه ثم ياتي بعض المحللين وبعض اساس
العرب ويلقون باللوم على اسرائيل ويقولون
ان اسرائيل هي من وقف اوراق اغتيال
الحريري او اسرائيل هي من يقف وراء القاء
البراميل على الشعب السوري يعني الحقيقه
والواقع لا تكذب نفسها بشار الاسد هو من
قتل الشعب السوري حزب الله وايران هم من
دمروا لبنان وكذلك الامر هم من يفعلون
الامر عينه فيه اليمن اذا كانت هذه
التنظيمات غبيه وغارقه في الغباء وغارقه
في السذاجه وتدمر شعوبها وتشرد شعوبها ثم
ياتي احد الناس ويقول ان اسرائيل هي من
تقف وراء ذلك وان عليه ان يراجع نفسه وان
يعيد حساباته بشكل منطقي وواقعي لان
اللبنانيين اليوم اذا ما سالتهم فانهم
يكفرون بلبنان وبعروبه لبنان وبسياده
لبنان واستقلال لبنان ويقول لك اين
اسرائيل حتى مطبع معها لبنان من كل
الطوائف دكتور فيصل
التواصل الاجتماعي اللبنانيين الشيعه
والسوريين نفس
العراقيين نفس الامر
والعراقي نعم هناك والعراقيين هناك وفود
عراقيه تحاول ان تصل الى اسرائيل تحاول ان
تمد الجسور الى اسرائيل واسرائيل تظهر في
الامر حقيقه يعني انها ايضا لا تفتح بابها
حتى هناك ليسوا هناك من هم ليسوا عرب
يطبعون مع اسرائيل يعني كلب اتراك والكرد
وقوميات اخرى تعيش بيننا دكتور فيصل تتبع
مع اسرائيل وتبني علاقات مع اسرائيل لماذا
يعيب العرب على انفسهم ان يطبعوا علاقاتهم
مع اسرائيل في حين ان تركيا كدوله ذات بعد
اقليمي واستراتيجي تطبع علاقاتها وتقيم
علاقاتها مع اسرائيل وربما الجميع في
سوريا وغيرها يحتذون بتركيا ويجعلونها لهم
قدوه حسنه تركيه والسيد رجب طيب اردوغان
كرئيس لجمهوريه تركيا هم يطبعون مع
اسرائيل نعم هناك خلافات اصبح هناك احتدام
حاد بالمواقف انسحبت سفراء طرد السفراء
ولكن هذا ما تمارسه تركيا ضمن سيادتها
والعرب ايضا تستطيعون ان يفعلوا ذلك يعني
موريتانيا طبعت علاقته مع اسرائيل ثم
اغلقت المكتب التجاري وطردت السفير
الاسرائيلي قطر كانت لديها علاقات تجاريه
مع اسرائيل وحبت بن جازم الشيخ حمد بن
جاسم بالامس في احدى التغريدات له على
التويتر قالها على صفحته الموثقه تويتر
قال نحن كقطر طبعنا مع اسرائيل وفتحنا
مكتبه تجاريا ولكن عندما وجدنا ان الوضع
لم يعد يسمح ولم يعد يفيد بالنسبه لموضوع
فلسطين والشعب الفلسطيني نحن كقطر الغين
واغلقنا المكتب وقلنا لهم تفضلوا واخرجوا
من الدوحه يعني بمعنى انت عندما تطبع
دكتور فيصل مع اسرائيل لك الحق ان تقول
اسرائيل لا معنى ذلك ان تقول لاسرائيل نعم
دائما اسرائيل ليست بعبع وليست جامبو
الجبار او ليست شمشون كما هي في الثقافه
جميل جدا والعبرانيه جميل جدا
يعني اسرائيل دوله جميل جدا جميل جدا كيف
ترد بس بدك تعطيني على انه يقول لك يا اخي
ليش
صحيح صحيح اما موضوع فبالتالي الاحتلال من
مصلحتها ان تبقى هذه المنطقه تحته يبقى هو
المهيمن وهذا معنى هم يريدون هيمنه
المطلقه عسكريا واقتصاديا واستراتيجيا
وامنيا وسايبر وكل شيء هذا هو الهدف
الوحيد غير هيك لا يستطيع العيش لان هذا
المجتمع في داخل السياره
يعني يتحدث فيه واحد في في صحيفه يقول
نتنياهو ماذا بقي غير يطلع بالطائرات هم
الان مختلفين بينهم البعض
ما الذي حقه الاسرائيلي من هذا التطبيع
احنا حكينا العرب انه حطيت امثله وهو لا
يستطيع الرد عليها فدخل في مواضيع اخرى
يقول لك انه التطبيع مسوي بالقوه هل
اسرائيل مساواه بالقوه مع السودان وتشاد
وموريتانيا وجزر القمر بالله عليك هذا
كلام يقال اين اين المساواه في القوه ولكن
ما الذي يحصل عليه اسرائيلي اسرائيلي من
هذا التطبيق مقابل العربي يحصل على شيء
تثبيت وجود اسرائيل وتامين دوليا لانه
احنا صرنا دوله من هذه المنطقه
حتى اليوم ضمان ام اسرائيل الذي لا يتحقق
الا بالتفوق الاستراتيجي الكامل الدول
اللي محتاجه لدعم اقتصادي مش عم تحقق شيء
ودول عندها فلوس مش قادره تحصل على اي
تقنيات عسكريه جديده تحويل قضيه الفلسطيني
جوهر الصراع الى قضيه اسرائيليه مع جزء من
الفلسطينيين احكوا مع بعض وزبطوا هذا هدف
اسرائيلي امتداد النفوس الاقتصادي
والسياسي والاسرائيلي في المنطقه كلها هم
يقول لك انه المجال الحيوي الاسرائيلي مش
عم نحكي على من الفرات يمتد من المغرب الى
الباكستان اي المنطقه الاسلاميه كلها هذا
يتحدث عن هذا الامر اي شيء في هذه المنطقه
بهمهم
وبالتالي التطبيع هو مصلحه الاسرائيلي
تماما ولا توجد اي مصلحه للعربي فعلا
الاخر اما موضوع التركي وغيرها الى اخره
يعني دائما نجد معارضه السفريه يعني اذا
نفترض انه غيرك اشرم في جريمه ما انت
بتبرر جريمتك وجريمه الاخر
فان هذه الدول لها مصالحها لا ننكر ذلك
وانا قلت ان التطبيع مرفوض بكل اشكاله هو
وصور وهو وس اي طرف كان ولكن هناك كما
ذكره وناقض نفسه هناك دول لما وصلت
الموضوع للقضيه الاساسيه القضيه المركزيه
تراجعت وانسحبت حتى قطر وموريتانيا امثله
تركي اخذت مواقف ولكن هناك دول اخرى تعامل
ضد القضيه الفلسطينيه في التشهيه والشيطنه
واللي هو حاول يعمل نفس الشيء اليوم في
تصوير الفلسطيني انه والله عايش ومرتاح
ومبسوط وبياكل وبيشرب بس بس دكتور ابراهيم
طيب نحن لماذا يعني لا نعمل بالمثل القائل
كما يقول البعض يعني مد المد رجليك على
قدر الحافه تعبير طيب انت تعلم ان اسرائيل
يعني من المضحك انك ترفض التطبيع مع
اسرائيل
وان وكل العرب اجمعين ينامون في الحضن
الامريكي الراعي الرسمي والاب بتاع
اسرائيل يعني اللي بيضحكك اكثر يعني انه
احلى شيء بيكون واحد نايم ليل نهار بحضن
فرنسا وقال شو قال يناهض التطبيق مع
اسرائيل بيضحكوا على هالشعوب والمغفلين
بصدقه نفس العمليه لواحد نايم بحضن امريكا
وبده يجي ضد اسرائيل انت تعلم
التطبيق مع اسرائيل ليس وليد اليوم ولا
قبل عشر سنوات ولا قبل 20 سنه ولا قبل
اربعين سنه كان عاده سريه والان تحول الى
الى علنيه باختصار شديد كله كان ماشي حتى
سوريا سوريا
خمسون عاما العدو والصهيوني العدو
والصهيوني عندما ثار الشعب السوري على
بشار الاسد
ظهر رامي مخلوف بين ليله وضحاها وقال امن
النظام السوري من امن اسرائيل فجاه
اكتشفنا انه هذا النظام عباره عن كلب
حراسه لاسرائيل هذا مين هذا السوري اللي
فضحنا بالامبرياليه والصهيونيه والعدو
والصهيوني وكذا وبقيه الدول العربيه يعني
هلق فقط انفضحت كانوا كانوا بيناموا مع
بعض بس هلق اعلنوا الزواج كلياتهم من
السودان وطالع وخاصه الجنرالات طيب انت
ليش يعني
تطبيع وما تطبيع يا اخي من زمان هذا
مطبعين وراكبين صحيح ولا ولا يمكن ذلك
ولكن هنا هنا اللي انا اوضحها في البدايه
التطبيع كان
اسرائيلي والامر والايراني متفقين انه
المنطقه انها تعنه قسما بس خلينا نتقاسم
العداء فيما بيننا ايران بتضغط على كم بلد
عربي بروحوا باتجاه اسرائيل وهذوك
وبالتاجر بحركات المقاوله والمماطعه
بتاعها هذه طيب صح ولا لا مئه بالمئه
هل تستطيع طب ليش مثلا التطبيع مع اسرائيل
حرام وايران تحتل اربع عواصم عربيه وفايته
يمين وشمال وكذا اليست التطبيع مع اسرائيل
على الاقل اسرائيل دوله متقدمه يعني شئت
ام ابيت من انك تطبع معه البلدان عيشه في
القرون ما قبل الوسطى طيب اول الموقف
الشخصي بتعرف الدكتور فيصل في هذا الموضوع
تماما لكن اشكرك على هذا ليش لانه التعلم
بانه والله احنا عنا خطر ايراني وبالتالي
لابد من التحافل مع اسرائيل تعلل غريب
عجيب ايش المشكله يكون عندك عدوين انت
علشان تحارب عدول اخر اسرائيل عدو مهما
حاولت تفعل لن تكون شريكا في هذه المنطقه
ايران صح في اربع عواصم من غيرها هي عدو
الان في هذه اللحظه ولكن انت طرحت متقدما
كذا لكن انا التشرد وهذا ليس رايي الشخصي
الشخص الموضوع ايران وموضوع المقاومه
والموانعه والكلام هذا ايران موجوده في
هذه المنطقه من الاف السنين جزء اصيل من
هذه المنطقه بينما اسرائيل جسم غريب غريب
سرطاني الى زوال الاحتلال الى زوال ما عنا
شك في ذلك الامر هذا وعد ما في مجال
وبالتالي المقارنه يا اخي هذا عدو بيشتغل
ضدك
هنا المشكله ان الان بحطك في العضله
الصفريه يا اخي اذا انت مش مع اسرائيل
جميل جدا ثائر الناشف لو مثلا عدنا الى
اخر يعني الايام الماضيه اذا صح التعبير
السودان السودان الان كما هو واضح ذاهب
باتجاه توقيع اتفاقيه سلام مع اسرائيل
بربك ماذا يستفيد السودان من من السلام مع
اسرائيل يعني ماذا يستفيد ماذا يمكن ان
تقدم له اسرائيل انت تعلم اين السودان هل
يستفيد سوى انه مثلا يتلحف
بالعباءه الاسرائيليه كي يحسن علاقاته مع
الغرب هذه هي القصه الوحيده ماذا يستفيد
السودان
وماذا استفاد غيره اصلا كما قال لك اعود
الى هذه النقطه كل البلدان كل البلدان كل
البلدان كل البلدان كل البلدان كل البلدان
التي التي تحاول ان تحل مشاكلها
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والثقافيه عفوا
والاجتماعيه بالتحالف مع اسرائيل او
بالتقرب من اسرائيل انظر اين وضعها الان
على وشك الافلاس والانهيار فلماذا السودان
يعني يذهب بنفس الاتجاه اذا شاف اذا شاف
اللي قبله شو صار فيهم كيف ترد
دكتور فيصل ليكون السؤال بالاتجاه التالي
ماذا استفادت دوله جنوب السوداني لان
الجنوب السودان هي دوله من اول دوله طبعت
بدول وادي النيل يعني بعد انفصال عن
السودان طبعت واستفادت في علاقات مع كبيره
مع اسرائيل واستطاعت ان تنفذ مشاريع
استراتيجيه مع اسرائيل ومشاريع زراعيه
واقتصاديه وتكنولوجيه كبيره ودوله السودان
انتبهت الى ذلك وايضا دوله السودان علينا
ان ننظر الى موقع الجغرافي من حيث حدودها
مع مصر ودول تكون لها العداء كاثيوبيا
وكذلك ايضا لديها توترات مع تشاد رئيس
تشاد محمد ادريس ديبي كان قبل يعني بضعه
اسابيع في تل ابيب وزاره اسرائيل وهذه
دوله عربيه كبرى دوله تشاد دوله شعبها
عربي اليوم ايضا هي تطبع يعني انتم لا
تحسبون ربما تشاد تشاد دوله عربيه تسعين
بالمئه من شعبها قبائل عربيه دوله عربيه
ايضا طبعت مع اسرائيل دول اسلاميه في
اوروبا طبعت ايضا مع اسرائيل كاكوسوفا
وغيرها خرجت من رحم الحرب من صربيا ودوله
اسلاميه في اوروبا ضعيفه اليوم استطاعت من
خلال تطبيع علاقاتها مع اسرائيل ان تتقرب
اكثر الى الغرب لابقى عند السؤال ماذا
يمكن ان يستفيد السودان من تطبيق علاقاته
مع اسرائيل العلاقات السودانيه
الاسرائيليه بدات منذ عام 1950 منذ لقاء
الصديق المهدي باريال
وبعد ذلك التقوا ايضا باريال شارون جعفر
النميري الرئيس السابق لقاءات عديده بين
المسؤولين السودانيين والاسرائيليين لولا
ان السودانيين لم يستفيدوا من لقاءاتهم مع
اسرائيل في الخمسينات وفي الثمانينات وفي
التسعينات وفي عام 2016 واخرها لقاء في
اسطنبول عام 2018 لما استمروا فيه العلاقه
مع الاسرائيليين الشعب السوداني شعب ذكي
وليس شعب فاقد للبوصله مطلقا يعرف مصلحته
جيدا ويدرك اليوم انه بعد الثوره
السودانيه التي حدثت سنتين اليوم يحتاج
السودان لكي يتجه اكثر وينخرط في دول
المنطقه خاصه في ظل علاقات متوتره مع
اريتريا
واوغندا وكذلك ايضا مع اثيوبيا اليوم
السودان يريد ان يرفع العقوبات عنه ويعلم
السودان جيدا ماذا استفادت الاردن ماذا
استفاد الاردن وماذا استفادت مصر ايضا
يعني من يقول كيف استفادت مصر من علاقاتها
مع اسرائيل والتطبيع مصر اليوم بعد ان
طبعت مع اسرائيل اربع جوائز نوبل حصلت لا
توجد دوله شرق اوسطيه او دوله عربيه او
دوله حتى في منطقه اسيا الوسطى او اسيا
الصغرى او في شمال افريقيا حصل شعبها على
اربع جوائز نوبل سوا مصر طبعا المصريون
حصلوا عليها بذكائهم وبدراستهم وبتحصيلهم
يقول الاستاذ ابراهيم ان اسرائيل لا تسمح
لاحد بالتفوق انا ادعوه لينظر الى
الفلسطينيين الذين يدرسون في الجامعات
الاسرائيليه عباقره يا رجل عباقره
الفلسطيني الذي يتخرج من الجامعات
الاسرائيليه يتخرج لا يقل عبقريه عن
الاميركان او الذين يتخرجون من جامعه ها
في حين ان الفلسطيني الذي يتخرج من جامعات
عربيه دمشق او بغداد او غيرها حاله لا
يختلف عن حال ايسوري او عراقي لان جامعتنا
دكتور فيصل لا تخرج النوابغ والعقول ربما
من الذكاء ولكن انت اليوم لديك مقومات
دوله قويه تعتني بالعلم والبحث العلمي من
الطبيعي ان تتخرج وان تتفوق وان يكون
لديها كل عوامل ومكامن القوه التي من
خلالها تستطيع ان تغير الواقع وان تفرض
تحدي كبير على شعوب المنطقه هذا ما فعلته
اسرائيل
باختصار ابراهيم حمامه انت قلت قبل قليل
انه اسرائيل رفضت شعبيا في المنطقه منذ
البدايه وانه يعني
ستبقى جسما غريبا والى ما هنالك من هذا
الكلام يا دكتور ابراهيم ما قيمه هذه
الشعوب او هذه القطعان انت تعلم لا تقدم
ولا تؤخر اسرائيل طالما وضعت يدها على
رقاب كل الانظمه والحكام العرب فثمن
الشعوب حق قشره بصل او نص فرنك مصدي اللي
كان يعطينا اياه جدي ابراهيم باختصار شديد
مش انت جدي ابراهيم انا اوكي طيب يعني على
ماذا بجملتين فقط هذا يثبت ان هذا
الاحتلال وهذه دوله الاحتلال لا تريد هذا
الشعوب ان ترتقي وتصبح ارادتها هي التي
تحكم بدها تضل زي ما انت حكيت قطعان لا
تؤثر لكن ان كانت هناك ديمقراطيه ستؤثر في
ذلك اما موضوع ان الشعوب وان هذه كذا هذا
ليس كلامي معها تبعتهم انا بدي اخس
مقرب من المؤسسه الحاكم في الامارات عنده
تغريد 25 يوليو 22
وسته اغسطس 22
اقراها وهو يتحدث انه لا يوجد تطبيق شعبي
وان التطبيع في الامارات تراجع بشكل كبير
جدا وهو نفسه ثائر ناشف عنده مقال في 2009
يقول ان ثلاثه ارباع يتبعوا طبعه بالمجان
جميل جدا ثائر الناشف الكلمه الاخيره
التطبيع الى اين على ضوء ما نراه الان هل
فعلا اسرائيل ستدخل المنطقه وسيحدث
التطبيع ام انها ستبقى فاشله باختصار جمله
[موسيقى]